irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
le centre du chili est la région la plus
peuplée et la plus connue la capitale
santiago et fondée par petro de valdivia
regard des costumes allure tout est
semblable à ce que vous pourriez voir ce
que j'avais vu à barcelone rome
bruxelles
c'est dans la capitale c'est à dire à
santiago que vit les trois quarts de la
population totale du pays santiago est
aussi le siège de la vie intellectuelle
et d'une grande partie de la vie
économique de mon avec jardin le santa
lucia et san cristobal en haut duquel on
accède par ce funiculaire
au sol mais une immense vierge de pierre
où l'on vient en pèlerinage
comme tous les pays de l'amérique latine
le chili est très catholique
cette vierge domine la ville avec au
fond la cordillère noyé dans la brume
valparaiso se situe sur la côte à 150 km
de la capitale
valparaiso est célèbre par son nombre
impressionnant de funiculaire qui
dessert une grande partie de la ville
perchée sur les collines environnantes
parfois ce sont presque des ascenseurs
le port de valparaiso mon premier de
chine valparaiso ou si vous préférez
vallée du paradis possède des rues
pittoresques
de magnifiques demeures perché sur la
colline le tout le style espagnol
le centre du chili forme une vallée
placé entre la pré candidats côtières et
la grande corne hier
ces grands vignobles font penser ou pays
bordelais les vins sont réputés et
prennent les noms de nos régions de
france
le climat ici est celui de nos contrées
mystères années m
et et la boue c'est l'après codières
ressemble au plateau de l'algérie les
cactus prolifèrent aussi bien dans l'
enfer brûlant du désert consommer
glacial des andes
certains d'entre eux atteignent 20
mètres de hauteur
on en sort des planches d'un bois poreux
plus au sud apparaît la grande forêt
c'est ici un merveilleux pays de lacs et
de volcans
vous avez le choix entre les l'acte
plein et les lacs d'altitude qui se
situe au pied des volcans couvert de
neige et de glace le plus beau et l'ours
nos aussi parfait sans doute que le fuji
yama cette région couvre plus de 80
mille kilomètres et la forêt et y ait de
plus en plus réel au fur et à mesure que
l'on descend vers le sud et que l'on
s'approche de la cordillère des sully
modernes se sont installés sur la
montagne surplombant lé lac à des
dizaines de kilomètres le tout chemin
non praticable à l'automobile
oh
c'est un bois rougeâtre qui est débité
sur place en planche souvent en forme de
traverses de chemin de fer descendu dans
la vallée le bois est traîné à même le
sol par des voeux jusqu'au bord du lac
et transporté ensuite par petits vapeur
l'attelage parcours souvent plusieurs
kilomètres dans le sentier accusant de
très forte déclivité
quand le sentier est praticable pour les
charrettes spécial monté sur roues
pleines ce sont elles qui se charge du
transfert ses roues sont directement
couper dans un tronc d'arbre
regardez ces cas autant mais amusant
de nombreux oiseaux vivent au bord de
ces lacs cormorans palmipèdes voisin du
pays tant il ce groupe dans société au
bord de l'eau les nids sont toujours
riches est niché sur la même marque il
supporte stoïquement le poids de cette
progéniture
restaurant l homicide
dans la cordillère jusqu'à 2500 mètres
d'altitude c'est la forêt qui prédomine
elle recouvre des milliers d'hectares
on la retrouvera jusqu'à l'extrême sud
du chili lorsque l'on s'éloigne pour
s'approcher de la voie de chemin de fer
et les grandes villes la physionomie du
pays se transforme rapidement la forêt
tend alors à disparaître
l'abattage des arbres destination les
scieries se fait sur une très grande
échelle des milliers d'arbres dont et
sont sacrifiés chaque année cette
destruction pose de graves problèmes est
le plus grand responsable est avant tout
le défricheur le défricheur qui brûlent
sans arrêt la forêt et attendra jusqu'à
quatre ou cinq ans le pourrissement des
souches pour passer lâche arnaud
sur le sol des boisés et sur des
dizaines de kilomètres on cultive le blé
une fois coupé celui ci est transportée
jusqu'à la batteuse qui sert à plusieurs
propriétaires comme dans le camp par
brest
puis le grain est transporté jusqu'au
moulin
au chili le paysan reste pauvre ils
représentent environ 30 à 35 % de la
population
malgré son travail actif les terres
cultivées n'occupe pas plus du quart des
terres cultivables le pays chilien était
avant tout une terre de pionnier il
devient à l'heure actuelle une terre du
bûcheron le cultivateur d'éleveurs le
régime foncier demeure celui de la
grande propriété
celle ci s'appelle fundo et s'étendent
sur des dizaines de kilomètres carrés
le bétail rentrer peu dans le circuit
commercial
les bêtes sont gardés par le gotchaux
chilien appelé le oisseau propriété avis
très souvent dans la vie ces terres sont
gérées par un administrateur qui est
logé avec sa famille dans une coquette
maison me plaire les ouvriers sont eux
aussi logés dans une maison de bois
le dimanche ils font parfois 20 km sur
leur monture pour se rendre rue des
hauts du village le plus près cette fête
s'apparente d'assez loin au corrida
espagnole est une particularité de cette
région du chum et maintenant assistons
gravement un pur
tous les concurrents se réunissent dans
une arène parmi eux deux et pendant
qu'un cavalier talonne une vache pour la
faire courir l'autre s'efforce de
l'arrêter à un endroit déterminé qui est
marquée par deux traits blancs sur la
palissade
si la vache sort notre chèr perd la
partie perdue
les vans shalio vous a proposé un voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec un film de gilbert le
montage on est gavé stripped jacqueline
loire sont mort eastbound claude gilles
son illustration sonore dominic
palladini réalisation solange péters